[Applaudissements]
petit peu à vous ils sont trois mois ils
valent un peu leur et à moi aussi à nous
tous finalement mais ouais il prend un
peu sur vous et ça c'est le seul moment
où peut-être un peu je suis sorti de mes
gongs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'amy est ce que vous avez volé à
ce que mokhtar a volé est-ce que vous
n'aurez jamais moi si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour que mokhtar
puisse à nouveau rentrer sur le
territoire américain parce qu'il faut
chaque grande carrière
mais c'est vrai et sachez que non alors
non là on a vu les a mais oui on a vu
les tutoz sur internet on est jamais
cachée seulement on a dit bravo à kona
ne regarder la version de conan et même
les airs et voilà savoir wen ont souvent
très drôle à part quand ils demandent
des choses un petit peu impossible
qu'est-ce qu'il a demandés et des
exigences c1 on a essayé d'y répondre au
maximum on a fait que ça toute la
journée la chronique de faim s'en
ressentira forcément mais voilà on a
répondu regardez déjà les exigences du
grand caudal voilà tout ce qu'il a voulu
faire garder un petit peu tout ce qu'il
veut qu'on fasse pour lui pour se faire
pardonner pour pâques et drame entre la
france et les styles rock band sortent
tous a dit anderson
[Applaudissements]
ravalement la savak c'est vrai alors
camille combal
on en est ici alors accès à quelques
roquettes alors pour la statue on est un
peu short dans la journée et la statue
au jardin du luxembourg on a fait notre
match mais je peux déjà annoncer à conan
o'brian on a déjà réussi au moins a
coiffé la regarder la tour eiffel avec
la même coupe que conan pour lui rendre
hommage vous allez voir regarder ce
qu'on a mais où ça a été fait cet après
midi comme ça j'ai un petit peu longez
le répertoire bien fourni
j'ai eu françois hollande et les fautes
il ya une heure il n'y a pas une heure
et il a été dévoilé il a pris la parole
en direct de l'elysée pour s'excuser
pour réussir ensemble voilà que ça
paraisse pas dans tous les sens avec eux
que 7,7 sociaux cette incision diplomate
sexuellement puis au calme alors c'est
très bien mais c'est qui la peluche à
côté de toi depuis tout à l'heure
domtar a des choses à dire aux états
unis ce sera dans un instant mais juste
avant on a le discours du président de
la république françois hollande s'est
exprimé sur cet incident regardez
écoutez
mes chers compatriotes les récents
événements survenus dans des pmp ont mis
en péril les bonnes relations entre la
france et les états unis
mokhtar et mons hausse c'est pour moi un
agent de sécurité en plein air c'est
pourquoi j'invite officiellement
monsieur konan brille coline coach conan
o'brian en france pour qu'ils discutent
ensemble
je viendrai le chercher moi-même en
scooter des poteaux à vous tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]